who would you consider to be your best
friend in the office what is davina like
in real life does jason actually favor
mary more than anyone else i wasn't very
happy about that you know maybe i do
talk a little bit
but i know the truth i'm just happy and
like go lucky all the time so if they
think i'm stupid for that then i'd
rather have them think i'm stupid and be
a [ __ ] hi you guys i'm heather ray
young
and i'm from netflix selling sunset and
i'm here with buzzfeed to answer your
burning questions
so first question how did you end up
getting into real estate
and then the oppenheim group so i was
modeling and acting
since i was about 21 years old i did
playboy that was my first
modeling job i ever did i started
thinking like what else do i want to do
i want to transition out
of this industry and into something else
so i had friends that were in the real
estate business
and they're like you know you're so
personable you have so many contacts you
know it'd be a perfect transition for
you
from that to real estate at first i was
like i don't know anything about real
estate i don't know anything about homes
my parents didn't teach me anything
about it and so i don't know i didn't
have interest and i'm like you know what
i can do this i setting my butt off i
passed the test the first time
and i sold a 7.3 no 7.2 million dollar
house and then a 1.5 million
dollar condo like two and a half months
after getting my license so i was like
oh i got momentum like i can do this
and then i was actually showing a
celebrity client one of jason's listings
up in west hollywood and that's how we
met
i joined the oppenheim group well let's
see when
it was like 2000 end of 14 beginning of
15 i want to say
well before it was even selling sunset
we interviewed for it
it's got to be three years ago now and
then netflix
ended up picking it up and then maybe
you know six months later we started
filming
how was the seating arrangement at the
oppenheim group's office decided
before we started filming selling sunset
you know we all had our desks but
you know occasionally i would sit
somewhere else if someone wasn't there
like we weren't all
there at the same time that was like
before we started filming and after
we started filming i don't know if jason
chose or adam
um our creator chose but yeah i got i
got put in the back
and as you see i wasn't very happy about
that but i felt like i was always like
yelling to everyone and i couldn't see
anything
i felt like i was like out of the loop
and not involved which i hate so i was
not happy about that
so what was the office dynamic when you
all found out about christelle's divorce
i mean i was devastated i was shocked we
all thought it was a joke we thought it
was like
you know this isn't real we were just
with her the night before the charity
event everything was fine she was happy
she was talking about
justin she was talking about you know
she was auctioning off things for justin
and
you know i'm a lover i think you guys
know that like i love love like i
believe in soul mates i believe in true
love and
from what i knew of their relationship
and them and things i talked to her
about
all i could see was love so it was very
devastating it was very shocking and
it broke my heart for her and you know i
cried multiple times for her
um after that after i was able to
process it and talking to the girl like
talking to my because my as a lover too
like maya and i were really affected by
it and
you know it was really sad seeing
krishna like that and you know she
didn't deserve what happened and
the whole world like she had to find out
the same time the whole world did and
you know it's
it's awful so you know it was
devastating for everybody
how long was it until christelle
returned back to the office after her
divorce news
did you talk to her at all prior to her
return krishele took a hiatus i want to
say
maybe two or three weeks she went back
to go be with her family
obviously like of course i reached out
to her i sent her a text i sent my love
i told her you know i'm here to talk
when you want to talk you want to go get
wine you just want to hug girl time i'm
here but i didn't want to keep
pressuring her and talk to her and ask
her these questions that i knew
the whole world was asking everyone was
reaching out to her the last thing you
want to do
is be on your phone all day talking
about the same story over and over
and she didn't know the answer so when
people are asking it's just like
i don't know so what's the point in
asking her and everyone was i just
wanted to leave her alone
give her time to relax oh davina
instigates a lot of drama in season
three and continues to bump heads with
nearly everyone even the boys
what is davina like in real life davina
is very opinionated she's a very strong
woman
and i think like the first time i met
davina she started asking me like all
these questions about my life like
within like five minutes of meeting
her and i remember like kind of like
after i walked away i remember telling
my girlfriend like wow that was like
kind of aggressive like the way she was
asking me like just like there was no
emotion it was just kind of like and
this and this and this and asking and
asking but
the longer we spent time together and i
got to know davina
she's a really good friend and she's a
really sweet person and she has a good
heart
she's just really hard on herself and
she's a hard worker so she pushes
herself a lot and i think
she's you know sensitive as well so
that's just who she is she says a couple
things that i don't agree with like
you know the boys and i comment and then
the two sides to every story comment i
just you know there's certain things i
don't agree with her but i do think
she's a great person and has a
huge heart and she's been a great friend
to me i've nothing there's been nothing
negative that she's done to me so i
can't say anything bad about her
are there more real estate agents who
work at the opponent group than
are shown on the show yes we're a
boutique agency it's still a small
agency but
there's probably around maybe 15 of us
we do have some guys that work there
um and then a few other girls that work
there who would you consider to be your
best friend
in the office that's changed a lot to be
honest
throughout the last couple years maya
and i used to be really close but
you know maya has two kids now she lives
in florida most of the time
i'd say right now i'm very close with
mary and christelle and i'm getting
closer with amanda
so when you aren't filming the show are
the ladies of selling sunsets still
selling houses and going to the office
yes we are this is our real career i
mean obviously with cobid things did
slow down a little bit for me i know
mary is working all the time jason's
working all the time
but i'm always in contact with the girls
i'm always in contact with jason i just
got off the call with him
but i'm still actively um working i have
clients but yeah all the girls we all
have clients and we're still working
have any of the women said anything on
the show during their solo interviews
that has caught you off guard or
reignited the drama yeah you know
i never know what the girls are gonna
say i never know what they're gonna say
in their interviews they don't know what
i'm gonna say
in season one we used to because we're
all friends like we really are but
you know we do really fight with each
other so sometimes you know during
filming or during the interviews maybe
they'd ask me about that
fight i had with christine and you know
maybe i do talk a little bit of [ __ ]
and i'll but usually i would like text
her after be like hey this is what they
were asking me about that fight we had
i just want to let you know like this is
kind of what i was talking about but i
don't want you to
get mad at me for it but you know we're
pretty good about that like we'll kind
of keep each other in the loop not as
much anymore
um but season one we definitely were
more like like had each other's backs
and things like that
i think mainly it was christine that
said a couple things about me being
stupid
or whatever but you know it's all good
fun
like she can think what she thinks but i
know the truth i'm just happy and like
go lucky all the time so if they think
i'm stupid for that then i'd rather be
happy go lucky and humble and have them
think i'm stupid and be a [ __ ] so
that's what i have to say so excluding
myself
who is the best at selling houses at the
oppenheim group and who needs the most
work
jason is definitely the best he's our
boss he's been in real estate for
i think 10 years on the one that needs
the most work i'd say probably
amanda just because she's the newest
real estate agent
and she was a designer turned real
estate agent and she's an incredible
designer so she's still learning and
it takes time and you need to be
mentored by someone you need to
like jason he takes the time to help me
he takes the time to answer questions
and
there's always new things in real estate
so there's still things i don't know
there's still things i'm learning
so you need to be with someone that can
teach you as a viewer watching season
three
it feels like the drama has torn the
women of selling sunset into two
separate clicks
is that accurate portrayal of the office
dynamic yes i hate to say yes but
definitely the group has been a little
bit separated especially
during filming season two and season
three i'd say i'm pretty
neutral in the middle but as of lately
i've kind of
you know went over to towards the
crechelle the mary amanza side and
you know i still am friends with davina
and christine i don't relate to them
with certain things
um lately but you know i'm neutral i'm
friends with all the girls and
i hope it stays that way but there's
definitely been a separation so
we all had a call yesterday we're always
on a tech we all have a group chat
and we're all cordial and great with
each other it's just sometimes we have
ups and downs and
we are a family we are friends friends
fight sisters fight and that's that's
kind of all of our relationships
there's contention in the office
whenever it seems like jason is favoring
mary
does jason actually favor mary more than
anyone else or is it just for the
cameras
i said this the other day mary works her
ass off
maybe in the beginning when she was
first starting jason
did give her some listings um to help
her out but
you know he helps us all out i don't
want to discount how hard she works she
does work her ass off i mean she showed
her
wedding venue and sold that house and
you know she's she's doing an amazing
job and i'm really proud of her so i'm
not going to discount how hard she works
and
jason doesn't feed her listings anymore
during your infamous
open house at the end of season two
christina mary's friendship hit a
boiling point
what are your thoughts on their evolving
friendship do you think they will ever
be best friends again
i still think back about that open house
and how much that pissed me off
um and very unprofessional for that
drama to be happening at my open house
but you know i really don't see them
being best friends again i see them
maybe mending a friendship
but at this point i think they have a
lot to talk about
and i don't think it's gonna happen
anytime soon okay so christine tends to
be painted as a villain in the series is
that an accurate reflection of who she
is when she when the cameras are not
rolling
i know christine a couple different ways
you know christina and i didn't get
along even
like when we were first filming season
one even when the cameras weren't
on before we even started filming and
selling sunset she didn't like me for
whatever reason or another i don't know
why
she didn't even know me i didn't know
her but you know over time we did get
closer and there was a period of time
when her and i were very close
and you know i i spent one-on-one
quality time with her and i got to see a
different side of christine
she has been different than that
christine that i know but i know her
where her heart is and i know that she's
a very sensitive loving person
but i think her insecurities bring out a
different side in her and maybe it's her
way of protecting herself i don't know
but sometimes it confuses me so i don't
really know where we're at right now
but i'll always care about her is
amanda's still late to everything
i actually had amanda on my podcast
yesterday i have a podcast called
flashbacks and amanda was early and i
was like i'm so proud of you
you know it's been something she's
struggled with her whole life and she's
very
she's an artist she's a creator and
you know she hasn't had to be like real
estate you have to be on time you have
to be very professional you have to
follow up with your clients
you have to get there before your
clients and make sure everything's set
up
especially when you're dealing with
multi-million dollar homes
and i don't think amanda knew how to
transition from
her designer world to the professional
real estate world
but i think we all gave her a lot of
last season
and there was a couple times when we
were filming we were about to have like
an office meeting and amanda was like an
hour and a half
late and you know we couldn't film we
had to wait for her and we're all there
i'm always early so i'm extra early i'm
always like at least 15 minutes 30
minutes early so i was always just
sitting there like ready to go
mic'd up waiting and this one day in
particular amanza was an hour and a half
late
and jason lost it he was just so pissed
off i think
you see that in season three you know it
was disrespectful and i think
we gave her so much [ __ ] and like
yesterday she said
we came down on her heart and actually
was a big wake-up call for her
you know i'm a little bit more easy and
going with her because of the stuff she
was dealing with that i
i didn't know she was dealing with all
that stuff at the time so maybe we were
all hard on her but
she's learning and she's getting better
that's all that matters in season three
you and amanda successfully worked
together on selling a house
do you regret your season two argument
during her first day at the office
you know i don't regret that because
that's how i felt
and the words that she chose were if and
when
tariq and i break up that's basically
insinuating that we're breaking up
so i think that argument kind of got
overshadowed like those words got
overshadowed by
you know the children the discussion
about the kids but you know she didn't
know me at the time
i think we had maybe seen each other
here and there at parties through mary
and jason but
she didn't know me she didn't know my
relationship with tarek she hadn't asked
me about my relationship with tarek so
i was not asking for her opinion you
know i do understand now where she was
coming from being a single mom and
dealing with
you know an ex-husband or a dating men
in her life that were in her children's
lives like i understand she had been
through it so she was just trying to
protect
the situation i actually texted her the
other day and i said you know i'm sorry
that i wasn't more sensitive
about what you were going through but i
didn't know what she was going through
we weren't friends she wasn't telling me
her personal business you know we've
mended everything we're great friends
now
and we talk all the time all right so we
see a lot of romaine and christian on
the show can we expect to see your
fiance tarik in any upcoming seasons of
selling sunset oh well i actually have
some good news so
tark is on hetv and unfortunately
because
the networks were not allowed to film
together but i was allowed to film one
episode
on his show flipping 101 which is on
hdtv
and also hgtv they filmed our engagement
you know i didn't know they were filming
the proposal obviously i thought they
were just filming more content to get
our
our episode to an hour that's what he
told me because they got to film the
engagement
netflix and hdtv came to an agreement
that tark is allowed to film an episode
with me next season
i'm so excited to have him on camera
with me and film with him we have so
much fun together and
we love filming together so what was
like entering such a blended family when
you started dating tara
i i gained a lot and my whole life
changed i went from being like a single
girl in la and now i'm
you know bonus mom two kids beyonce um i
moved my life from
la down to newport and it's
been a whirlwind but you know everyone
gets along great
everything's for the kids they're the
most important they're number one
as long as they're happy we're all happy
so that's all that matters we have great
communication
and yeah everything's great what has
been the most produced storyline in the
series thus far
i mean nothing's produced everything is
our real life
um obviously like you know for certain
purposes for the setup
they have us in the office or they have
us like having lunch um maybe we
wouldn't have chose that restaurant but
production that that's what they chose
and that's the you know scene we're
filming but everything else that happens
is organic
when do you film the solo interviews
that we can see on the show and are you
able to watch any of the show's footage
prior to
release so usually we don't start
filming the interviews right away
they'll wait until a few months until
we've got like a lot of coverage
and we filmed quite a bit and then we'll
go back and we'll film the interviews um
based on like what we've filmed
so far and usually based on the
interviews i'm kind of like oh that's
the scene they're going to use or oh
they're going to use that when i went to
that restaurant with her or that fight
so i can kind of like guess what they're
going to use but
we don't get to see any of the footage
until right before the release
so i just got to see season three i want
to say it was like three days ago they
sent us the link and we were all like
well tark and i we stayed up like binge
watching it usually we watch it all as a
group
but because of cobid we haven't been
able to what are the biggest differences
between jason and brett
jason and brett are very similar they're
twins but their personalities are
definitely a little bit different
jason is very strict very hard on us
doesn't have a lot of patience for the
girls
like he'll ask me a question about
something in my personal life and i'll
sit down i'll start talking to him and
he'll be like
okay i can't do this anymore like i i i
can't i can't listen anymore like i i
don't have time
so it kind of brushed me off i'm like
that's not nice and then with brett
he's a little bit more sensitive so
he'll listen to all of our girls
problems and
you know he'll give us like advice and
he's just a little bit more like chill
than
than jason how has covid impacted
oppenheim group
and has season four been filmed yet i'm
down in newport beach which is about an
hour and a half
from la i've been down in newport for
the last like six months pretty much
full time i go up to la still for
listings and appointments um it's just a
lot harder to get up there but
oh we have not filmed season four we
have not even heard if we're getting a
season four that's depending on how
season three does
so binge watch you guys the more you
binge the more you watch it
uh we'll get a season four if selling
sunset lasts several more seasons which
it will
uh where would you want to see yourself
by selling sunset season 10 oh my gosh
well i'm gonna be married yes i'll be
miss el moussa so i'll be changing my
name
um i would love if the kids could film
with me so i'm hoping next season
i could film with the kids tarek
hopefully will film with me more
i hope to sell a 20 30 40 million dollar
house on the show and
i'm actually going to be helping tara
flip a home so i'll be helping with a
design i'll be helping flip
so i would love to bring that onto
sewing sunset okay you guys make sure
you catch me
and all the cast of selling sunset
streaming now on netflix and
also listen in on my podcast it's called
flashbacks
it's so fun i get a bunch of girls in we
talk about our past so
it's really fun light-hearted and i'd
love for you guys to listen
you